west street and great to see you how's
the new job good morning day two and i
think it's very clear that i'm gonna be
pretty busy so don't ask me what my
christmas plans are and whether i've
changed them because i think i did that
two days ago when i was given this job
but i think last time i was on i talked
about my experience with kidney cancer
earlier this year i mean having been
through that and looking at some of the
news today about nhs waiting lists
cancer waiting times
you know this is a job that's really
important to me and we've got two
important jobs as the labour party one
is to hold the government to account
work constructively with them
in the course of tackling this pandemic
which isn't over but also looking ahead
to the next election to set out a set of
policies that people trust and believe
in that reflect their priorities and
their concerns and that might lead them
as they look in on this government which
has been let's be honest in recent weeks
a bit of a shambles with working people
paying the price that people might start
looking to labor as an alternative
government and put their faith in us but
a lot of work to do and i'm looking
forward to getting stuck in okay what
would your plan be
if you were in government at the moment
when it comes to people going to
christmas parties
we want people to continue to enjoy
christmas as usual and if the government
does everything within its power
then they should be able to continue to
do that so myself and yvette cooper the
shadow home secretary have called on
sajid javid and priti patel to introduce
pre-departure testing for all arrivals
into the uk from overseas
that means that we'll put an end to the
frankly bizarre situation we've got at
the moment where people can travel on
busy transport to the airport go through
the busy airport be on a busy flight
arrive into a busy arrivals hall travel
home on busy public transport without
having had a test that would seem to me
to be a sensible precautionary we didn't
have that previously and um i did put
that to steady jab he said yeah we did
do that we don't need to do it anymore
i just don't think given that only
yesterday the house of commons has once
again asked people to make changes to
the way they go about their lives it's
only right the government does
everything within its power to reduce
the risk of this variant or new variants
coming into the uk
seeding themselves in communities across
the uk and spreading and you know the
we've seen time and again the cost of
that in terms of lives livelihoods and
liberties is a high price and not one we
should ask the british people to pay
unnecessarily as a result of government
in action so um constructively robustly
we've asked the government to take that
step there are other things they can do
in terms of anti-viral treatments which
give us means of potentially treating
covid19 let's make sure we're speeding
up the evaluation and approval of those
treatments let's make sure that we are
taking action on things like ventilation
and other sensible measures that can
reduce the impact of the virus and as
for the booster campaign this week we've
called on the government to do half a
million booster jabs a day they've
fallen well short of that so having
challenged them and clearly having
listened let's let's get on there
they've not always fallen well short of
that they have actually reached five
hundred thousand on occasion on occasion
and they're on hundreds on occasion but
i think what we've been saying to the
government is redouble your efforts use
community pharmacy pop-up testing let's
enlist new volunteers and to be fair to
them they've listened so we're going to
get right behind that booster campaign
and also encourage people where they
haven't had perhaps their second jab yet
or even their first to take up that jab
you know we want the government to be
successful in this we want britain to
get vaccinated and we want to minimize
the the risk of this virus both in terms
of the spread and transmission and also
the impact on people's health should we
be about this omicron variant i mean
it's transpired this morning that um
it's been detected as far back as
october in the uk yeah look i think we i
think we we monitor the science all the
time in terms of the severity of this
virus in terms of its transmissibility i
think that's why as i said the
government's got to take every
precautionary step
and also let's not include not mingling
at christmas
well if the government does the things
that we've asked them to that shouldn't
be necessary bear in mind that
throughout the pandemic in terms of
testing in terms of in terms of
vaccination and in terms of treatment we
are in a different place to where we've
been earlier on
and from you know my point of view the
labor party's point of view we don't
want to disrupt people's lives any more
than is necessary and we think if the
government does everything that we've
called on them to do we've recommended
that they do then it shouldn't be
necessary for people to change their
christmas plans so how does that square
with people
working from home because you want
people to work from home don't you but
you're saying work from home but you can
go to a party
well i think people can make
sensible choices and and precautions but
we don't look i just think the point is
kate no one wants to be the grinch and
that cancels christmas we we don't want
people to have to go through what we've
been through previously in terms of not
seeing family and friends and enjoying
themselves over christmas and we
genuinely think if the government does
those things that i've outlined this
morning
of course
accelerates the booster roll out as they
said they will but those other things
i've mentioned in terms of
testing before people board flights
or transport into the uk from overseas
action on ventilation and action on
anti-viral treatment these are all
things that mean that we can go about
our lives as normal because the
objective here let's remember we're not
going to eradicate covid the objective
here is to make sure that we can coexist
with the virus without the kind of
devastating concept i understand and and
labor criticizes the government for
mixed messaging and i and i hear that as
well because we're hearing two sides of
that uh same coin but you're but your
party you say work from home go to your
christmas party we're not saying people
compelling people to work from home it's
about making choices and i think people
are making sense but you understand
that's a mixed message they are making
sensible choices i don't i don't think
so actually kay i think i think people
are thinking about how they mix when
they mix
and and the kind of the risk trade-off
and i think it's perfectly reasonable
for people to say well i'm not going to
go out about unnecessarily but of course
christmas is approaching i would like to
see my family and friends and that's a
reasonable choice for me to make i don't
actually think that's mixed messaging i
think
where we've got to this week with the
warnings from jenny harris is clearly an
anxiety
that the government isn't quite doing
everything that they need to the the the
the virus is not an action to get on top
of the virus isn't being as successful
as it could be that's what we need to
get ahead of so that people can enjoy
christmas as normal and that's what we
want to see and does labour support the
um 10-day um
isolation if you have been in touch with
somebody who's got the coveted variant
well yeah if people that could ruin
people's christmases it it could but you
know we got to take the precautionary
principle on the new variant and as i
say you know we we don't want people's
christmas to be ruined we really don't
uh and of course you know i mean i had
as well as cancer i've had covid um as
well and you know i can see through the
awards i know tell me about it i mean
honestly i think i've taken mystery
shopping in the nhs to the nth degree
this year so i can tell you quite a lot
about um various patient pathways and
experiences during the course of um this
last year um but of course if people
contract the virus they always have to
isolate at home and one thing we're
saying to the government as well is is
don't make that a fun actually people
who don't necessarily contract it but
are in contact with it yeah of course
that's the distinction but i'm also
saying of course if people can track the
virus itself they still have to ice and
of course if people can trap the virus
itself they still have to isolate at
home of course that is going to be
necessary uh uh and the government needs
to make it possible as well so one of
the other things we've urged the
government to do is take action on
statutory sick pay because i think we've
had too many examples yeah of people
feeling that they can't afford to
isolate home and we don't want that to
be there what is going on with your boss
and your deputy boss uh so kirsten has
issued a save the date for christmas
drinks with journalists based in
westminster nfi um but he hasn't well
that's his first that's his first big
mistake this year
well he's not invited it makes you feel
better so you know but he's not invited
angela rayne what's that about
i i don't know that that's i don't know
that's true well apparently it's true
are you saying it's not true no i don't
know what if it is true i don't know and
also i imagine angela's in undated and
if she isn't well me and you can get
together for christmas drinks on the
same night
yeah our party will be better can i just
say i know keira and angie very well and
we were in shadow cabinet the other day
together i do think so much of this is
like is really overblown actually there
isn't no i really i really just not
really no i really do think that you're
protesting no i'm not actually no i know
them both really well i count them both
as friends we've got a really good
united team following the shadow cabinet
reshuffle and we've got a lot of work to
do to win back voters trust i do think
some given what we've been talking about
this morning in terms of people's in
terms of what we talked about this
morning in terms of people's christmases
the sorts of things people are worried
about today i really don't think
angie or keir's christmas party plans
are top of the list of people well i
think they're very interested in if you
are going to be a part of the fit for
government whether or not those two at
the top are getting on or not look what
happened to the labour party previously
when uh gordon brown and tony blair
started falling out you know they were
basically ripping lumps out of each
other the question is how much
involvement did she have in the
reshuffle you'd have to ask and my
understanding is that angie was
consulted knew the reshuffle was
happening um but you know i just i i
genuinely think okay in terms of the
sorts of things that worrying people
today and the sort of priorities we have
as a labour party this kind of
westminster title tattle is least of
people i'm just a bit worried that you
keep calling her angie um it's good to
see you
a really good friend of mine a good
colleague excellent it's good to see you
let me know what the date is for our
party yeah we'll get together thanks
very much wes thank you